thanks i'm going to
draw together some of what my colleagues
today have said and then some of what we
heard yesterday especially in the
section the session on on climate i'm
going to
talk briefly i think about kind of the
underlying
you know kind of essence and and and
characteristics of what we call the
global nuclear order
and then i'm going to try to explore
what i think are some of the again
deeper causes of the disorder that my
colleagues have talked about
and then briefly suggest some uh things
that can be done that
that kind of build on or add to what uh
they had
they had talked about michael
you know began by talking about
in essence you know at least one of the
pillars
of what became a global nuclear order
after 1945 and he talked about how
remarkable it it
is that nuclear weapons hadn't been
detonated in
anger against targets since
1945 and i think that's the the essence
of
the accomplishment of the nuclear war
but there were additional facets to it
there was a tremendous worry
um that nuclear weapons would
proliferate to other countries so
famously uh president kennedy's
administration president kennedy was
briefed that 25 countries would acquire
nuclear weapons very quickly
very soon um if things continued uh
as as they would um and and so
for a variety of reasons particularly
the u.s and the soviet union cooperated
to
[Music]
create the nuclear nonproliferation
treaty and that was
negotiated finally in 1968
and basically since then since that
treaty uh
was done and entered into force in 1970
there's only been one country that
signed the treaty
then cheated on it and acquired nuclear
weapons
and that's north korea it's quite a
remarkable achievement if you think
about
international treaties you think about
anything you think about domestic
legislation
and crime and and and to have you know
that rate that small rate
of violation uh you know that somebody
gets away with
uh is is is quite remarkable and so that
was another element of this
global nuclear order and then the third
element of it was
was um peaceful cooperation in atomic
energy so if you think about it
and i'm going to come to this later um
because today
nuclear energy isn't very attractive
except in a few non-market
uh societies or or economies
but but there are lots of i
should know how many nuclear power
plants in the world but it's
around 450 thereabouts um
and and in many countries and that
operation has gone relatively
um what's gone very well in terms of
people cheating and building nuclear
weapons out of those
uh civilian nuclear programs and that
was another part of this
nuclear order that was created and i
guess what i want to say about it has
been a remarkable
success and and it in its
what was key to it is it's
built on um reliable reciprocity
that's an expression that i borrowed
from lauren berlant
who is a she's like a literary theorist
at the university of chicago that i'd
never heard of until two weeks ago and
then i
i checked out a book that she wrote and
a lot of it's hard to read but then
there's some really brilliant stuff in
it too
that i can't understand and one of these
and i used to talk about
um sustainable reciprocity and but she
has reliable
reciprocity which is alliterative and
just great so
i stole it and i'll quit footnoting it
you know hereafter
um but but that's what it was built upon
that that if you restrain yourself
uh if the weapon states restrain
themselves if if they agree to work
towards nuclear disarmament
and others restrain themselves from
acquiring nuclear weapons and you play
by the rules
everybody does better through that kind
of reciprocity and it's some of what we
talked about yesterday
and other elements of multilateralism
it's it's central
to multilateralism and it's key to the
nuclear order working
as i said the non-proliferation treaty
was the essence of it and so here i'll
borrow from something kevin rudd said
last night about the u.n which
which was based he said look if the u.n
didn't exist we'd have to invent
something like it well if the
non-proliferation treaty didn't
exist we'd have to invent something like
it
except today it would be much much
harder to
invent and get international
subscription for
than it was then so in many ways it's it
it's
it's all the more important um to uh
to defend and and and to invest in uh
restoring and the last point to
again set the stage about order and how
important the order is and here
in here i'm i'm picking up on something
um professor yan said which is
if look at how we're worried about
artificial intelligence
uh today cyber more broadly but
artificial intelligence especially has
people very concerned whether it's
automated weapons
you know aircraft everything people are
worried about especially the
international dimension
and there is no order there there's no
domestic regulation
there's no understanding of liability
domestically
internationally they haven't even become
discussions of it
and so when you think you juxtapose
that kind of nascent stage of of
technology burn
burgeoning lots of concern about it
there's a
sense that it needs to be ordered no one
has a slightest idea how it's going to
be done
well that was kind of where nuclear
began in 1945 and so it's quite
remarkable how quickly
and successfully an order uh was built
in in that domain and we should hope
that we can figure out how to do this
well with ai and some of these
uh technologies but if that's going to
be the case i think we're going to have
to
go back to the fundamental principles of
reliable reciprocity
quid pro quo's and creating incentives
for people to to comply so that leads me
to the second
section which is um my sense that
that what we're experiencing in a lot of
the problems that people
here uh talked about whether it's the
inf treaty being
uh first violated and then uh you know
with withdrawn from
the absence of arms control the dprk
challenge
the iran undoing there's a long list the
arms race
i think what's happening is you have
disinvestment
from this nuclear order and
disinvestment
from at least two blocks
of of of country and and i would i'll
suggest there are four factors driving
it so
the u.s and i would say russia
are disinvesting from that nuclear order
for somewhat similar reasons the u.s
disinvestment
is is really intensified
and made explicit by john bolton and and
president trump but really
uh john bolton makes it explicit and the
idea is
look there aren't many threats of
proliferation anymore
all right like name the country that
we're now worried about will acquire
nuclear weapons the one that people
nominate is saudi arabia well first of
all from the bush administration that
isn't the biggest problem
in in the world so then the next thing
is okay so tell me a bad guy who's going
to get nuclear weapons now
and the answer of i'm sorry of the trump
administration and john bolton is
we'll handle that ourselves militarily
uh so we don't need all these rules in
this rigamarole and all these bargains
and concessions and
and trade-offs you know screw it if
somebody does it we'll remove them
and that was basically the bush
administration strategy in 2002
with the axis of evil that's the
strategy that led to the invasion of
iraq and iran was supposed to be next
you know or
north korea and and so the the approach
is you don't
it's like the nra says about arms
control the problem isn't
arms it's not nuclear arms the problem
is bad guys with nuclear arms and so the
strategy is not to control the arms
is to get rid of the bad guys and and so
it's a coherent
uh theory that leads to disinvestment
from that kind of
order and i think russia is disinvesting
for somewhat related reasons
russia is more concerned about selling
nuclear power plants about making deals
in countries that may be
uh seeking to acquire nuclear energy and
if there's a worry that those countries
like saudi arabia may seek to acquire
nuclear weapons we'll deal with that
later or that'll be the us's problem or
somebody else's
problem but it's not the first concern
and
and beyond sales the bigger concern is
contesting and countering
uh the us and trying to play off
challenges with other countries
as a way to gain leverage over the us
i think the second factor causing dis
disinvestment is
that nuclear energy is no longer
attractive it's not attractive enough
for
developing countries to make them go gee
i want nuclear energy
so badly that i'll do whatever these
people are telling me to do in terms of
export controls
not acquiring nuclear weapons behaving
well so that i can get nuclear energy
look at it now and i'd say after
fukushima especially but also
just prices it's it's just not a a great
investment china is the only country
really that's got a kind of
still a burgeoning nuclear energy
program and so i think that changes the
dynamic within the
the nuclear order um the third
kind of disinvesting uh uh you know
dynamic is that the disadvantaged
participants in this order ones that
feel their victims are primarily the
non-nuclear weapon states
the countries in south america africa
and parts of asia
that feel they get no benefit from
nuclear deterrence
all right so you know unlike our nato
ally u.s nato allies unlike russia these
countries go look we
we don't face threats for which nuclear
deterrence is relevant
these countries aren't going to defend
us um and yet if they have a big nuclear
war we get screwed
like our our food supply is going to be
endangered
we are going to be dealing with the
global chaos that will uh
come of that and and so they say um
we want to morally protest this we want
to disinvest
uh and and and challenge this system and
so they
basically led negotiation two years ago
of a treaty to prohibit nuclear weapons
right frustrated with the
non-proliferation treaty feeling that
the nuclear weapons states are never
going to get rid of nuclear weapons
they said the hell with it we'll just
we'll negotiate a separate treaty that
just said ban them prohibit them
period um it doesn't matter if it's not
binding on any of the
weapon states will make our stand uh on
there
and we're less interested now in in
non-proliferation
i think the the fourth uh driver of this
disinvestment is something that we've
been talking about which is um
new technology so whether it's
artificial intelligence
hypersonic conventional weapons that
nikolai talked about
other kinds of systems people kind of go
on
those are the new threats that we really
got to be worried about
nuclear is kind of the old it's not
clear how nuclear arms control and the
existing system's going to deal with
these new technologies
so let's focus on the new technologies
and spend less time and energy
on on the old ones so from different
directions you've got some people
arguing from like a security narrative
saying
they're disinvesting others from a moral
or humanitarian narrative saying they're
disinvesting
from this order and all of that is
compounded
by the lack of leadership from the u.s
because
new orders basically whether they're
trade as we talked about yesterday or
climate
and nuclear you need at least like one
of the biggest powers to try to drive it
preferably you'd have two so the nuclear
war was built by the us and the soviet
union
we talked yesterday todd talked about
you can't do climate without the us and
china
i would argue i mean that both of those
things are true
and on the nuclear we're going to have
to have the u.s russia and china
going forward and if you don't have that
cooperation you can't basically
you know restore the order so that leads
to what can we
do about it um in my mind you know the
first thing is
something that none of my colleagues
think about and that washington doesn't
think about at all except maybe
president trump
um and this is a serious comment and
kind of praise of him it's not praise
but it's an accident but
um how do you get uh
russia off the sanctions track so russia
had
a bunch of sanctions imposed deservedly
in my view for what it did
in ukraine but the problem with
sanctions is once you've applied them
you you've kind of defeated the purpose
you the behavior that you are trying to
change you know doesn't work so in
russia's case
how do we move forward how does the
world move forward
russia's never giving back crimea i mean
never is a long time it's not clear when
and why russia would give back
crimea uh it's still meddling in
in ukraine the sanctions are there putin
is really pissed off about it he wants
those sanctions removed there's no
dialogue or even thinking in the west
how to remove the sanctions
and so if you want to get russia to come
back in and play on these other issues
how do you motivate them
to do that seems to me a vital issue
that no one's really
thinking about and then with china how
do how do you
um deal with
the territorial aggrandizement that have
people so concerned in the south china
sea so the building of
of islands out of rock out outcroppings
or adding of runways onto to things that
alarm
asean state japan the u.s and others
um we have to deal with the and then
china is concerned about what u.s
intentions are in taiwan if you don't
address those underlying issues it seems
to me it's very hard to then get into a
serious discussion about strategic
stability
and and tempering or controlling the
military including the nuclear
competition but again we don't have a
dialogue with china on strategic
stability we don't we're not engaged in
uh that that process and that was a
problem before the trump administration
and
it's been exacerbated uh by trump so
i've got a list of other things that are
very similar to what came up in the
climate
uh discussion about accountability and
equity
so there are larger things than arms
control but it seems to me if we don't
address those
the multilateral order around nuclear
weapons
is going to continue to experience
disinvestments i'll stop there okay
thank you
[Music]